[Music]
we got a mukbang over here
i'll do it hell yeah there we go wow
can't wait to see how this correlates it
correlates
because i asked them to keep eating
that's can we stop if you want
okay you can eat just don't make the
ruffle noise man
all right so the way it correlates is
because this story is about a
three-year-old little girl
named pei shing and she
is so her parents are a chinese couple
and they film mukbang videos of this
three-year-old little girl
but they're getting a lot of backlash
because
of the apparent appearance of the little
girl so they're saying that they're
abusing her and that they're using her
as a cash cow
and that she's uh overweight
and that she's not healthy and that the
parents are not
good parents so that's because they're
making money off her eating
oh and she's eating too much and that
she's eating excessively
according to viewers and people are just
demanding that uh the parents
be held accountable asians love making
fat babies though
they do they love making they think it's
healthy yeah exactly the more they have
the better the more they'll grow
but then don't they start telling you
that you're fat yeah
that's yeah later tell babies
hey you fat ass you're never gonna get a
husband yeah but it sounds like chinese
people are
uh calling them out yes chinese social
media maybe they changed
maybe who knows but yeah they're saying
that it's just
sparking outrage and
yeah they're saying like i said that
they're abusing their child
and yeah but the parents are saying
that she's a healthy normal little girl
she that our videos don't only include
her eating food but as well as losing
weight and dancing
and she's always been a big child and
the the mom said she's my birth child
why would i intentionally feed her that
much because you're getting paid
hella money i mean yeah you would say
that after you're getting called out
yeah the father said we have jobs and
don't lack money we just want to record
the growth of our child we did make a
little bit of profit maybe a few hundred
yuan
but that is just a number to us that's
what the dad said
so they're saying that the made like a
few hundred bucks or something
yeah what is the a few hundred you want
that's like three bucks
like how dare you [ __ ] exploit your
child
right i mean if it's just ad revenue 14
that happens man people monetize like
people fighting and stuff yeah you know
what i mean like and i don't really know
what the
what's the norm for a child or whatever
like i mean she
to me because i could only gauge off
tycho like she doesn't look a bit brown
but a doctor could probably be like oh
that's perfectly normal within this
range
like a fat chubbier kid for you but that
baby looked like humpty dumpty a little
bit though
yeah the mom said that she weighed about
like nine pounds at birth so four point
five kilos
oh so she's like she's already big yeah
nine is pretty big what is the average
baby pound
six seven yeah
she does that now at three years old she
weighs 35 kilos
no like 35 kilos 30 yeah which is 77
pounds wow
to put it into perspective because you
guys know taika
he's also three he's tall but he's not
big three
he's uh he's almost about to be 40
pounds
almost so she's i need a swimmer she's
twice his weight
yeah wow so she's obese right
yeah i technically speaking probably
well yeah what is she eating in these
videos like
spaghetti it looks like watermelon that
looks like ice cream
70 pounds for a three-year-old that's
that i think that's
seven almost 80. yeah that's bad i told
you she looked like humpty dumpty look
at that
i love that she loves to eat food though
that makes me happy i knew girls in high
school who weighed less than that
so okay that's wrong too they were small
it's hard to just judge you know what is
being shown
everyone has a different perception
social media so i understand that side
but also
you know there's some evidence that we
are seeing
there's a fat [ __ ] baby should we
interview the high chair to see if it's
getting stressed out
one of the like uh you know daily mail
the tabloid website
so they claim that there was this video
where the little girl told her parents
to stop feeding her
and then they they only gave her more
food
oh that's sad that's sad like a
livestream or some [ __ ] what do you mean
she was like i don't want to eat no more
yeah well that's that's that's the claim
stop feeding me
yeah keep feeding and then that the
plate immediately got filled up again
uh matilda right no is that yeah yeah
with the
the chocolate yes the chocolate cake
cake oh yeah that scene
right now sweat and blood went into this
cake yeah
you will eat it yeah that's my favorite
movie ever were you guys forced to eat
as a kid
yes yeah i was and that's why i became i
had a [ __ ] food problem
throughout my whole life my parents told
me that i kept asking for food and they
didn't know what else to feed me
oh wait because i was allergic okay
i didn't give us that context first
i i wanted to eat all the stuff that i
was allergic to oh
how hard i i basically grew up paleo
without
knowing what paleo was just mainly like
beef chicken
fish and then like vegetables because i
was allergic to rice
even eggs milk a lot of grains
breads yeah so i mean
we find out now that that's actually
healthy right but
um because i got so much eczema like i
couldn't eat the rice when everyone was
eating rice i wanted like i was like ah
rice [ __ ] [ __ ] you know and
then uh but i love
meat though and uh they were just like
how the [ __ ] does this kid feed
all fit all this food but i remember
later
uh like in elementary school if i didn't
clear my plate they would get mad at me
and they're just like you gotta finish
all this food
if you don't finish it you're just
wasting it there's all these people in
the world that can't eat you're
ungrateful
whatever right i think we all had that
yeah yeah always
but it was i was like dude but sometimes
mom you can't cook like this is
disgusting man
it's hard to eat man that's what i was
thinking oh it just didn't taste good
like it's hard to eat a whole plate if
it tastes like [ __ ]
what'd you say out loud same thing no i
was like oh i'm so
full and then later when i got older i
was just like i don't like your cooking
that much
and then she's like yeah me neither yeah
seriously she did she's like i don't
like to cook either it's just
it's just [ __ ] work but um i uh
eventually someone told her that you
shouldn't
force them to eat because everyone has a
different size stomach and they didn't
think like that
so then they're like they just hearing
it from another adult their age i think
was like oh okay so so they all develop
differently and they all have different
appetites
and then they stopped force-feeding me
at
cause they're like yeah he's just gonna
get super fat or something
so i got lucky because that
force-feeding thing was a short period
of time
yeah yeah that was pretty much my like
when my parents were together so from
like birth to seven
like all that time my dad would horse
feed me like eat
why the [ __ ] won't you eat my mom wasn't
she was really like
passive or whatever she wasn't about
that but my dad would like grab
my like behind my head and like jam food
in my mouth
and i'd be sobbing and crying and he
told me you're not leaving the [ __ ]
table until you're done and i'd fall
asleep next to my food and my mom would
like
pick me up take me to the room and stuff
but it was [ __ ] traumatic that's why
you don't like food that's why i don't
like food i only eat to survive
mainly i mean now that i'm getting older
i think it's gotten
less but still yeah it's your
association to that past
yeah but you know right and then it's i
feel really guilty because
i ended up like unintentionally
doing the same to isaac but obviously
not the exact same or like force-feeding
like crazy but
it ended up becoming a
i don't know a really difficult process
every time we had a meal
up until he was about eight years old he
finally
stopped but you guys saw it like every
time we'd go out to dinner i'm like
begging him like isaac please you need
to eat like you're gonna
die on me kid you don't eat he always
winks at me and he goes watch this
and then later i sneak him food under
the table he's eating it see i just
wanted him to eat
i'm just like please you need to stay
alive
somehow we went to japan and we took him
we borrowed him for that one day
he was killing it on the japanese
barbecue
yeah yeah around that age is when he's
he calmed down
around like seven ish because he was
seven there yeah he was
killing it so that's when he was like i
feel like that's surprisingly common
because my friend his nephew
and his relationship with his sister
which is his nephew's mom
um is they have a similar situation
where he just
does not want to eat and stuff and his
sister
always just yells at him like top of her
voice just like
why won't you eat and like he explains
to me like her voice sounds like a demon
you know like it changes to this thing
and he like you know the kids just
crying and sitting there at the table
and just like
and i'm it sucks because i don't think a
lot of people realize too like
then now the kids connecting this trauma
with the food now they can't eat the
food because of the trauma and it's in
the cycle
so what happens i mean like won't the
kid just eat when they're hungry like
why don't you just leave them there what
depends it depends like
if your kid has like stomach issues for
example it doesn't like you could try to
force them to eat because the
pediatricians going like well they're
underweight you know but then it's like
this kid has this association to food
that's gonna hurt
its stomach for example um or like taika
he just
he's a very picky eater was he always
picky oh
uh when he was first born he wasn't that
picky he actually ate a lot but just the
older he got he just was disinterested
with food um and we can just go all
right forget it you don't have to eat
this
but then he wants to snack on some other
stuff and for me i'm like well wait you
need your nutrition dude you can't just
snack on like
they're still hungry but they just want
to fill themselves up with them that was
milk
you know with tasty things yeah or just
milk because he's like in the milk
he loves milk he goes yummy yummy how
cute
yeah so it's rough it's rough on parents
man no wonder people just kind of give
the kid what they want they just give in
because they're like you want mcdonald's
all right [ __ ] i give you mcdonald's
you're gonna die
stupid yeah then do they have followers
um instagram followers i don't know how
many but obviously enough to
grab the attention of many people and
say that this is child abuse
so they're saying that there is a their
officials are investigating into this
family to see if there is
child abuse um but yeah like
people are upset they're saying this is
jolly view some people don't deserve to
be parents this is making me so angry
it's one of the comments
but yeah that's one of the things i
always think about when i see like
kids that are acting for youtube like i
hate that my mind goes there but i
always have to think like
damn do these kids even want to do it
like once once the adults are like
turning a profit i'm like at what point
are these kids going like no i just want
to play i don't want to rehearse this
[ __ ] or i don't want to do
family vloggers and stuff not so much
the family vloggers because they're
the if they're a family vlog then the
center isn't so much on the kids or the
kids having to learn lines or having to
like rehearse like i see child actors
yeah you write lines for tiger and he
has to say it the right way right
for the stories yeah cause we do family
vlogs but it's not centered around taika
it's just tyka so happens to be there
and that's what's happening in the
moment but if like it was
you're not exploiting obviously yeah but
like when i see just specific kid
content i'm like damn i can't imagine a
kid being excited to be acting for x
amount of time to make this toy
all the time stuff like that or like
it's like make-believe [ __ ] or like
they're the princess of the castle or
they're like selling ice cream and i'm
like for how long does a kid stay happy
to do this
i don't know right i think that it's
tough too because there's probably not
necessarily like a union for like
youtube
specific stuff like how you know gary
coleman that whole thing happened with
his parents where
there was an actual law where money had
to go in a separate bank account
you know separate from from what they
had
um what what they were earning from the
tv show so now child actors you know
they'll get
not youtube but there's no union for
youtube to like
make sure that the kids are are being
protected in that sense so i totally
feel you yeah
i know that's why like now whenever
there's something that that
we're filming or a vlog or whatever
we're always like
isaac if you don't want to do this just
let me know
because i do not want him to one day
look back and say you forced me to do
this like you forced
like you invaded my my private life or
whatever so i'm just
super mindful like i mean i think it's a
little obvious here that it might be
against that kid's will yeah if she's
saying stop feeding me and then they
fill up the plate again that's pretty
bad yeah
she's like twice the weight that she's
supposed to be at
especially that the fact of that yeah 77
pounds is
it's a lot
[Music]
you